okay thank you it's my pleasure to be
here today and I want to talk to you
about something that all of you have
done but which probably very few of you
have actually thought about when you
were doing it and it affects all of us
and that thing is contracts specifically
what I refer to as rap contracts and so
some of you might be wondering why are
we talking about contracts in this class
this is a computer science colloquium
and not a log law school class well
contracts in case you haven't noticed
control pretty much everything you do
online not only that it controls pretty
much everything that has to do with
software which is no kind of interest a
sorcerer sort of strange and the reason
it does is by design it's by design of
software companies as well as design of
their lawyers okay so wrap contracts
affect you both as a producer of
software and technology as well as a
consumer or user of Technology and I
want to talk today about what you need
to know in order to use them in an
effective way to protect your work but
also what you need to watch out for as a
consumer of technology okay but first
some context when you think of a
contract you probably think of a bunch
of small print on thick paper that you
signed with a nice pen like this and the
slides are not being recorded because I
didn't get permission for all the
photographs so just thought I'd let all
of you know who are your life okay so
usually think of a contract that is
multi-page you probably signed one when
you bought a house or what have you a
wrap contract is not this a wrap
contract is any non-traditional non
negotiated contract
meaning it's a contract presented to you
on a take-it-or-leave-it basis in a
format that wasn't generally used before
let's say 1970 in other words you don't
sign it with a pen most of you will be
familiar with click wraps that's where
you click with a mouse on the on and
accept icon or tap wrap swear on your
phone you have to tap before you can
proceed on whatever it is that you
wanted to do on online there are also
browse wraps which are hyperlinks which
say something like terms are terms of
use or legal or something to that effect
and those are known as browse wraps now
how do we get here and are these really
contracts that are enforceable under the
law because there's so many of them well
let me give let me start by giving a
little context because I I understand
that this is not a contract law class
alright the model upon which contract
law spaced missing slide there is two
people negotiating terms which are to
his or her own advantage okay but with
technology and industrialization we were
able to get mass produce goods consumer
goods like the singer sewing machine now
these machines were great because they
really improved efficiency right the
problem was they were really expensive
too so consumers couldn't buy these even
if they really wanted to because it made
their lives a lot easier maybe much more
productive and so because they couldn't
afford to pay for such an expensive item
the companies had to come up with a way
to allow them to use the machine without
paying for all of it up front ok so the
installment plan was born consumer
credit was born even more so then the
sewing machine was the automobile it was
really the automobile that fueled the
pop
zation of installment plans and really
vice versa because without consumer
credit there would be no automobile
industry because very few people back
then and today can pay for cars in cash
upfront the way that you go to the store
and buy anything else ok so these credit
schemes were implemented with standard
form contracts ok and these standard
forms that the terms on these forms were
sort of were standardized and there were
a few variable provisions and that was
it ok so it was really contracts that
helped shape the market for automobiles
and sewing machines and other big-ticket
items like that now standard contracts
proliferated because companies found
them convenient and efficient for
certain standard transactions and they
used them with both other companies as
well as with consumers but while other
companies were allowed to negotiate
terms consumers typically weren't courts
recognized these contracts as contracts
these standard forms as contracts even
when they were contracts of adhesion
meaning that the consumer wasn't able to
negotiate for different terms and so
this was very different from the sort of
prototype of a contract where you have
two people negotiating terms right
bargaining and much of contract law all
of contract law up until the era of
standard forms all of contract law was
based upon this idea of two parties
equally matched and and negotiating
terms to his or her own advantage and so
courts applied contract law even though
this model the standard for that the
contracts of adhesion was very different
from negotiated contracts ok um these
contracts of adhesion can take different
forms now up until the past 20 or so
years maybe maybe more if you count
notices and so forth but most consumer
contracts were signed right most
consumer contracts were signed but as
you all know that's no longer the case
and that brings us to wrap contracts
okay mass consumer license agreements
evolved from a business reality that was
confronted by software companies and
this a software this a business reality
was that software companies are really
an uneasy with the way that their
software could be easily copied right it
could be easily copied and distributed
and so they try to find a way to get out
of the first sale doctrine and for those
of you are unfamiliar with us at first
sale doctrine that it's basically under
copyright the Copyright Act it says that
when you buy something like a book for
example you can sell your copy of the
book even though you can't make copies
of that book okay so you can you could
you can sell or transfer your copy of a
copyrighted item even if you can't you
know make copies and distribute
otherwise okay so software companies
thought hmm this could be problematic
because somebody could buy a copy of her
software and sell it but they could have
in the meantime made copies of the
program now I'm sure none of you ever
did that right not not even back in the
eighties but um any event so that was
that was one of the reasons another
reason is because software is was very
buggy and so they wanted to put
limitations of liability and warranty
disclaimers somehow in their product
okay so they came up with a license
model as opposed to a sale line so
that's why even now even today you don't
buy software I mean you some of you
might have thought you did buy software
but you don't buy software you license
it okay it's a licensed versus a sale
model okay and in doing that software
companies tried that the reason they did
that was they try to get out
the first sale doctrine that was one of
the primary reasons okay what okay so
the model was pretty ingenious really
when you think about it as far as the
sneaky lawyer tricks right but there was
a small problem in that we that you
don't want to slow down a sales
transaction by having your customers
sign something can you imagine if every
time you bought a software program you
had to actually handed it at that the
what was it the via egg what was the
company I went our business eggs egg
head yeah you would say egg head of the
acres a good store and they said here
you gotta sign this before you can buy
that you'd say wait a second I've been
doing that right so they had to come up
with a way to have consumers enter into
a contract without the transactional
hurdle of having them sign something so
the shrink-wrap license was born
remember this M estas ok well the
shrink-wrap license was named because it
was a license agreement encased with a
CD or floppy I guess at the time and it
was wrapped in plastic and so when you
unwrap the plastic to get to your disc
the piece of paper would fall out and
that was the license agreement but the
piece of paper that fell out you did not
sign right you didn't sign it but the
Court recognized in a famous case called
pro CD versus edinburg that this shrink
wrap license was a legitimate contract
form and you accepted it when you saw
that there was a contract inside you
have the opportunity to read it even if
you didn't read it and you didn't take
the product back to the store so you had
an opportunity to read the terms and you
accepted it because you did not reject
it ok so this
you can return software ease oh that's
what as they say and the other thing is
what everything add since at frogs for
sale it doesn't say it for license
exactly what why doesn't their
terminology I now find them not only
that um that you know with at Lisa a lot
of my guess is that the way they
recognize sales is also based on you
know a sale models opposed to a
licensing model so from the accounting
standpoint so yeah I agree with you and
I've actually written papers arguing
raising those points because it doesn't
really make any sense but I will know I
when we take that back I may not like it
you may not like it but there is a
justification for it even if we don't
agree with the justification and what
that justification is is that the courts
were starting to change the rules of
contract law to accommodate the concerns
of the software companies because they
thought this is a new industry we don't
want to stifle it with yeah there were
some bad actors in the end those day so
kind of okay there's no law in this area
so what are we going to do we'll just
make copies and we'll start their own
businesses selling somebody's pirated
software okay in any event the courts
saw said that this was a legitimate
business model is a fish I mean a
contracting model it was efficient and
we're going to recognize this as
acceptance when you don't return the
software even if it is a legal fiction
as you pointed out but it's unreturnable
big yeah exactly right and and they
don't have to use the word sale that was
their choice right they could have said
for license but most consumers are gonna
say what what are you talking about it i
buy their prized exactly right that's
exactly right there selling bananas they
can't call them oranges well they are in
this case so um after the shrink-wrap
you started to see what courts referred
to as click wrap agreements and that's
where you have to click accept okay
and the court said that you accepted the
terms when you clicked because you
didn't have to click although as we all
know if you don't click you can't
progress the court says well so what you
know you know there's no requirement
that you that a website accommodation
has to let you continue on their website
okay and then you've got the brows wrap
the brows rapid is the hyperlink here at
this terms of use this is an old-style
at Google Terms of Use and there it's a
hyperlink to a page containing legal
terms which you except when you see the
term see the hyperlink and you don't
immediately get off the website and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in a second although I can see that
you're already really not happy with the
current analysis which is which I like
because I don't think it is is right
either okay now you start to see what I
refer to as a multi wrap okay and that's
where you have a browse wrap and then
you've got the cliq so you've got to
click to sign up but the terms aren't
immediately visible they are next to a
hyperlink to the terms okay that terms
yes which of course I probably don't
know what who's clicked on that I'm just
get a guide me but very few people have
actually clicked on it and we'll talk
about the design of that in a second a
little later okay so first let's we're
going to look at these contracts from
two sides first as a producer of
software like from the standpoint of us
a software company and if we were going
to use these agreements how do we how do
we employ them so that there's a high
likelihood that they will be legally
enforceable and then I'm going to jump
the fence and look at them from the
standpoint of a consumer and say
and you know what do you need to know
because these contracts may be enforced
against you ok so the law in this area
is is still developing it's it's very
new it's still developing and so there
are things can change but there are some
things that are sure and so if I were to
let's say give some advice not legal
advice of course I've I supposed to give
advice about how do you make this
contract enforceable if you're building
a website or something then I would say
you should definitely have a cliq
element on there ok um so the recent
court decisions in force electronic
agreements either click or browse wrap
if there is and this is the this is the
law here actual or constructive notice
and either a manifestation of assent or
an opportunity to reject terms ok but
what counts for a manifestation of a
scent is often not rejecting terms after
having notice so really seems like what
the courts are fixed fixated on is this
idea of was there reasonable notice
reasonable notice being either actual
notice that there were legal terms that
govern the use of the website or the
software or was there constructive
notice meaning that you should have
noticed the terms ok that's constructive
notice a reasonable person would have
noticed them so the cases are really
kind of messy in this area and the the
way the court supply contract law the
doctor and the rules of contract law is
very different from how they apply them
in the context of other types of
contracts and so it's really kind of a
mess a little bit in this area for
unless you have read through all the rap
contract cases which i think i have so i
want to give you some general guidelines
that might help ok
first there's generally sufficient
notice when the consumer has to click in
order to continue on the site so if the
consumer has to click and the terms are
immediately viewable or they're
contained in a scrollable box or they're
contained in a hyperlink either above or
below the icon that requires clicking
like we saw on the Facebook page okay so
here's an example it's kind of hard to
see but that's those are terms contained
in a scrollable box even though you
don't the terms are not immediately
viewable and you have to scroll down
because you have to click to continue
the courts are likely to hold to say
that that is an enforceable contract now
there was a point in time in the late
90s maybe early maybe like early 2000 so
where it we weren't quite sure whether
or not the terms had to be immediately
viewable in order to be enforceable but
since then cases there have been enough
cases that that doesn't seem to be
something that's required okay so as a
developer as a user if you wanted if you
were creating a website for example and
you wanted to make sure that your terms
of use were enforceable I would
definitely have a cliq element in your
as part of your contract okay and so you
want to make sure as a developer that
your contract terms require that your
users click to accept the terms okay now
let's jump on the other side of the
fence as a user or consumer of
technology or a website don't think that
just because you didn't click you're not
going to be bound okay because there are
also cases that say that the terms are
binding even if you didn't click okay so
if you want to be safe clicks okay
that's say you know that's what I would
say if if you want them to work in your
favor but if you're up against them and
you did a say wait I didn't click that
doesn't mean that you're not bound by
those terms okay
alright so what up miners if you chew
them do that it works that's all
different can of worms but believe that
this is another area where the law
differs sort of regular traditional
contract law differs from online
contracts because yeah usually if you're
a minor you don't you know the contract
is not gonna be binding on you the way
they do that's mine well their way they
justify that is there is a sort of a
caveat to the infancy it's called the
infancy doctrine and that caveat is that
that to put it sort of simply it's that
if the minor is getting benefits they
have to give the reasonable value of
what they're getting and so if they
continue to use a website then they
can't say the terms don't apply to me so
there have been it's it's a very it's
kind of an interesting again a
developing area of the law as well ok so
there's generally sufficient notice when
the consumer or the user uses a website
but doesn't click in order to proceed
and okay so there's no clicking okay I
mean and they might may not have even
seen the hyperlink but afterwards they
get a cease and desist letter because
they're doing something that they're not
supposed to do that's against the terms
of use of website and they get to see
some distance letter so they have actual
notice that okay or they don't click but
there is a hyperlink which is visible on
the website without scrolling and the
the the hyperlink says something like
terms of use are illegal or something to
that effect like this paper or does it
have to get a registered email no
stubborn just an email so if you appear
in a span bucket you would never know
well then you do get actual notice so
so it has to be like when a process
server serves you the letter it doesn't
even have to be that if you're sending
it again if it again if you're if if
you're going to send that you want to
make sure they get it then you don't
want them to say oh I never got it but
if they respond in some of these cases
you know there was there's been some
back and forth an email and so you can't
later say oh whoa I didn't I never got
that first email okay so here's an
example of at the very top there's a
notice okay and you have to click
continue to continue but actually on
this website you don't actually have to
click to continue and continue our
website without clicking but you don't
have to scroll down in order to see me
the notice and here's another example
yeah it kind of hard to see isn't it
right you don't have to scroll exactly
all grey on slightly dirty let's go that
doesn't say anything I terms of use it
says we use cookies okay so go so what
that does is oh so just in terms of use
but what you've done is you've agreed to
allow them to use cookies yeah yeah
that's all you're agreeing to agree but
if it here's another one okay so we use
cookies to ensure that you get the best
experience on our website but nature's
website you agree to our use of such
cookies okay there i didn't find their
other actually other websites that have
notices similar i just want to give an
example but some of them will say terms
of use at the very top a lot of them
however don't put the terms on the oh so
this is a case that says that on this in
this case the website said by continuing
past this page and are using the site
you agree to abide by the terms of use
for the site which prohibit commercial
use of any information in the site and
even though the user didn't have to
click that this was deemed to be
sufficient notice okay yes if by
clicking on the hyperlink that's in
terms of use
okay and again here I want to compare
that with another case that if you don't
click OK and a consumer uses the website
and there's no indication at the time
that the that there are terms that apply
or that their forthcoming then a court
is not likely to find sufficient notice
so if it's at the bottom of a page no
they're not going to apply they want the
terms of use want to play I don't know
if any of you have fallen for this trick
but sometimes if you buy something
online after you're done the last page
there's this little i notice that comes
up that says get your some discount
right ten dollars off your next purchase
or something like this and you click and
you think it's the same website that you
just bought stuff from but it's not as a
different company okay so you have
inadvertently signed up for this other
service and they will debit you you know
five dollars a month until you notice it
and they'll send you an email that sort
of submerged and that says that these
terms apply and you've got to click on
the link to the terms and that's kind of
what happened this case in the court
said hey wait a second they didn't have
to click on anything at the time they
supposedly unrolled you sent them an
email after the fact and that's just too
that's just too convoluted it's not
something that constitute sufficient
notice okay thank goodness right because
that's that's that's carrying things a
little too far okay you were it wasn't
just the first case you have listed was
a web crawler and they're saying if
you're using automated means than your
assumed to have seen the terms and could
be bound by them there were three
elements there yeah there were a lot of
different yeah there's realize but if
it's not automated let's say I use a
browser that is defective and through no
fault of my own that for some reason
never displays the words terms of use or
the link
it's a defective browser I've got crappy
internet service at home I don't get
that link i don't see look i never saw
the link i think i have no constructive
notice no matter where it was on their
page they didn't deliver it to me well
see okay so the standard is constructive
not actual you're looking at actual
notice and so the question is if you
have a defective browser mm-hmm would a
reasonable person having a non-defective
a browser would they they'd be bound but
i'm not using i'm not that purse so
that's not the standard the standard
isn't what whether you have actual
notice it's actual or constructive so
somebody else could be belly and are
these folks they actually I believe them
when they say they didn't know what they
were they don't remember clicking it all
these cases were more people say I know
it was clicking or I didn't see the link
or what have you but um and I think yeah
that's probably right because I'm sure
that most of you don't remember most of
the times you can because it's just
becoming this reflex right but that's
not the standard well no I wasn't
worried about the cookies notice you had
constructive notice that it's your fault
that you don't that your browser doesn't
work and um I'm not see there is no
actual case on point like this okay so
there's no actual so uh yes you could
definitely make the argument and if I
were you and this became an issue I
would make the argument that i never got
notice but you would have to argue that
not that not just that you didn't
actually get noticed you would have to
argue that it was a reasonable person
okay it's it's not that unusual to have
a defective browser okay so it's really
not sort of strange or you weren't being
unreasonable in continuing to use this
browser it was really up to the company
to make sure that their images and you
know text display on all sorts of
different it in all sorts of I could
imagine somebody running with javascript
disabled in some way is ever yeah for
all the monkey bouncing trapping
javascript and
something about them no javascript kills
and so soon as I know there is no case
dealing with this precise issue but
courts have sort of sort of talks about
what if right what if and they without
actually having a case on point and I
think that it's going to come down to
whether or not it's what you're doing is
reasonable use an old ones that it does
is make a scam website amazoncom which
explicitly has in terms of use in return
for reading this this website if you
continue you always thousand bucks click
here you bury it down there in the terms
oh my god and then build up oh yeah I
actually have something oh actually get
pearly whites up halfway through but ok
so there is one case out there zappos
okay where the terms of use were at the
very bottom of the page and the court
said wait a second the terms of use are
inconspicuous they're buried in the
middle to the bottom of every Zappos web
page but the user does not have to click
on them in order to buy their shoes and
so because of that the terms of use for
not binding because they're at the
bottom they were not immediately
viewable and the user was never asked to
click okay so at least there's some line
there some line in the sand there okay
so here's this beautiful a flowchart
that outlines you know was there
reasonable notice and this is kind of
the analysis the court is going to go
through basically what I think it comes
down to is this the courts are treating
these online contracts as notices the
way that you would if you put a notice
on your front yard or notice it in a
store okay so let's say that you have a
store and you have a sign that says no
smoking now let's say that somebody else
walks in and they smoke and they didn't
see the sign it doesn't matter you can
still kick them out right it's your
story okay what you can't do is they
walk in and you have a sign that says no
smoking if you smoke it will cost you
one hundred dollars
and they smoke in the side and see the
sign he said you got to pay up pay up a
hundred dollars it wait a second that we
can all agree is something you can't do
you can only allow that through contract
okay and I think what's happening is the
courts are confusing this idea of notice
that comes up when you're a property
owner or business owner this
proprietorship when you're when you're a
proprietor versus a contract situation
where I don't have the right to get to
take the hundred dollars from you unless
you agreed to my terms before you
entered the store right and that's why
when you go to a hotel you have to
separately initial that that that a
provision that says if you smoke you've
tried to pay two hundred dollars for the
cleaning fee right and that's why they
have that's why to have you do that it's
not that they can't tell you not to
smoke at their hotel they can the
question is then what if you break their
rules then what they could definitely
kick you out but what else can they do
well they can't take away something that
belongs to you unless you agreed to it
okay and I think that's what's going on
in this case and that's why when
somebody has actual notice even if they
didn't see even if they didn't see on
the when they were on the website they
didn't know that they weren't allowed to
do certain things I weren't allowed to
scrape the content or what have you or
deep link or whatever it was the if they
get actual notice and they continue to
use the website they can't say well
technically there's no offer and
acceptance here under contract law
because you know you're not supposed to
do it and this company has the power to
prevent you from using that site okay
alright so the courts have generally
said that electronic contract digital
contracts are the same as paper
contracts there's no difference okay but
as we know they are very different with
a paper contract you have to sign and
even if you don't have the ability to
negotiate terms like I didn't negotiate
with the car rental place today I know
I'm signing a contract online a lot of
times people don't know
what they agreed to they don't even know
there was a contract what I asked my my
students in my contracts class okay so
when you signed your contract facebook
and they say what like contract with
facebook they don't know you know they
don't think about it okay the other
thing is that the rules are different in
that with electronic contracts the
courts apply this idea of notice as
opposed to acceptance right when you
sign a contract that's acceptance of
terms but in when it comes to wrap
contracts they're doing something a
little different they're using notice
instead of contract or consent under
contract law there's something called a
duty to read which is really a
presumption that if you have signed a
document that you've read the Terms okay
and you can't later say well I signed it
but I never read it okay because that
doesn't usually fly and we can
understand why that might be problematic
if we allowed people to get out of their
contracts that they signed by saying I
never read it but online it's a
different issue because your so called
duty to read is triggered by
constructive notice this idea that you
should have noticed something so we're
getting even further away from this idea
that it's fair to hold you to these
contract terms since we have this small
print I adopted small print not read is
that legal I cited a very small print
yeah I've actually seen people for some
reason that sentence ugly thing it can
you argue at least well we still find it
so over the copy you said said I I
reject these terms and if they accept
this counter but it's the question is
then why did you sign it it's so the
resumption is it I was forced to force
to sign yeah one point basically okay so
that's there's the rest of it
actually weather got involved wave was
the hard way gun but well there are some
tough situations uh when we're talking
about paper contract such as well
contracting sonars but online it's just
getting a little too crazy and the
reason is that like we said when you buy
something buy some eggs at the store
they don't say oh can you please sign
this contract here okay if they did you
would say you know I think I'll take my
business to another store okay but with
a digital contracts with rap contracts
the contracts are intangible they're
weightless you don't even know what
you've done and you don't know how many
pages are in there because it's cheap
right you can reproduce the terms and
because consumers don't look at them
they're not even aware of this contract
the terms are much more aggressive okay
there's another reason that people click
or sort of that that this idea of notice
doesn't really make sense when we're
talking about the way people actually
behave and it has to do with something
called in attentional blindness I don't
know if some of you have any of you have
seen this this video but I actually
thought it a science museum but there's
a famous study by Christopher sure
breeze and Daniel Simon's that involves
subjects that were asked to watch a
videotape basketball game and on one
team the members were white shirts and
the other team members were black shirts
and subjects were asked to silently
count the number of passes made by the
white shirt 'add players but to ignore
the passes made by the black sure did
players okay so in the middle of this a
woman wearing a gorilla suit walks in
and stands among the players thumping
her chest and about half of the subjects
the participants in the study failed to
see the gorilla suited interloper yes
exactly yeah I gave this presentation
was I I told this sunday in a group of
lawyers law professors and somebody
raised his hand he said that's not real
that didn't
that's not look that didn't actually
happen he said I do not believe that
anybody could actually miss the grill i
said that's because this is a still in
the video you can easily miss it because
there are black shorted players and you
know this person is the gorilla is
wearing it's a black suit right and so I
actually did too and so i told him i
said well i have to tell you why i saw
the video at a children's museum and i
missed the gorilla and i said it's a
video it's not a still but he just he
couldn't you couldn't believe it he
thought really i think it's like fifty
percent uh yeah it's it's a famous study
right and it's not just relegated right
yes there's multiple phases and then
after you see it again and you know that
you're looking for the gorilla then they
say did you see this other thing there's
like four things you miss yeah yeah
they've done different yeah but in the
same video so you so they tell you see
it again and this time you see the grill
up as you don't see right because your
focus on so that so my point is that
when you're online you're focused on
something it's not signing a document
like when you go to a closing to close
on a house you're focused on clothes on
those closing documents you may not read
them but you know it's illegal there's
there's sort of a formal environment
there whereas when you're online you're
not thinking about a legal environment
you're focused on something else and so
if all these people who say I SI must
have clicked if I couldn't proceed by
the clink I must have but I don't
remember it and the judge after the fact
is saying oh we don't believe you how
could you not you because the judge is
it is doing a sort of an after analysis
you know they're looking at this and
saying well you know because they're
looking for that they're looking at the
notice they're looking at the click on
are saying how could you not have seen
that well that's because they're looking
for it but in terms of useless on this
page if you have a question yeah we do
what do you say he'll fill out this form
and after what you say where was the
terms of use I'll say what like my
students right so but it's it's into
interesting that that judges impose this
this duty to read and the duty to read
is that Ari
person would have read the terms but the
fact is no reasonable person reads these
terms yeah let me ask the same the other
things oh then yes degree yes that was
sneaky or whatever exactly you know I
there's so it's not just a matter of you
know when I talk to other lawyers
they'll say well is this any different
from you know when you go to a car
rental place and you have to sign an
agreement or your credit card company
and yet there is an element of
powerlessness when it comes to boat but
it's different online because there's so
many contracts and the signaling effects
are really gone there I mean you may not
agree with what your bank is doing but
at least you know that there's something
going on there where's well cuz in
California you can use any name yeah
that isn't a permit let's say that if
something happens and you want to do
something about it yeah so it's not it's
not this is going to help you in some
cases a pseudonym is not read hidden
basic well I don't think that's the look
if that's gonna help okay so via the
presentation of digital contracts is
also different from paper contracts with
paper contracts you sign at the end
right and you have the number of pages
that you can a so you you the thicker
the document the more important the
transaction right and you can skim dock
your pay per documents with digital
contracts you sign at the beginning
right usually it's you you click before
you know what's what the terms are and
you can't tell how long they are so I
think that for example here you have to
fill out all your information and then
you click sign up so at that point
cookies used before the film
well you do you read it to use before
you flatter me I certainly do before I
put the sign on okay so this is what
most people will do is they will fill in
that the field okay at that point you
can click terms or cookie you sir what
will any of these hyperlink terms now if
you do that do you think you're going to
lose everything it is a new window gonna
pop up or your sometimes you will lose
everything that you just filled out yeah
and so most people you think I know what
even if a new they're not going to take
the Rue set a new it's it's not going to
erase everything Vader spending and
they'll just click sign up and it's in
upper medium gray over a lower medium
playing background but uh here's another
example paypal you fill out all this
information and then you click yes I've
read and agree to the following but they
don't even give you the terms and so at
that point you filled out all this
information which everyone hates to fill
out their personal information and then
and then you how many after the fact are
going to click on the hyperlink yeah my
cousin well everybody else is everybody
who's not using licks columns with the
way the with digital contracts because
the form so you're ambushed at the end
you know they're there are also
hyperlinks a lot of hyperlinks so the
contracts are a lot longer and there's
something known as a unilateral
modification clauses okay and this is a
cause that says well even if you did
make it to the terms of use the first in
the first couple lines it usually says
something like we can change these terms
at any time and and you will have
accepted them if you continue to use the
website after we've changed the terms
okay now I call that a bait and switch
practice because what happens is like
with some companies like Facebook for
example they
may have privacy provisions that you're
okay with when you first sign up and
then you've got then you start to build
your network right you put stuff on
there your network grows and then they
change their terms and you're not as
happy with it but okay okay and then so
on and so forth until you're really not
happy with the terms that that you have
now but at that point you've got sunk
costs right and you're gonna have
switching costs and so you don't
necessarily want to change even though
you're not happy with the terms and
that's what you get thanks to unilateral
modification classes and there are also
other reasons why consumers agree to
these terms there's just too much
information with all the hyperlinks
right there's this sense that hey
everyone else is doing it right do you
want to be the only one not on Facebook
yeah I am I'm sure in this room okay
okay but uh but frankly I am the only
one that's that I know at my family and
they always you know they always say
what's the matter with you but the fact
is you know if you're not happy with the
terms I if and if you view it as a
contract then you wouldn't sign up but
most of them don't read the term so
they'd you know it's like a bit of an
ostrich there's also something known as
the optimism bias the idea that yeah
there are these nasty terms in there but
but that's that's not gonna happen to
you all right somebody else it's it's
the idea that you know only the top 10%
can be the top 10% but hey you know when
you're in school you think well but
that's gonna be me right okay there also
we talked about sunk and switching costs
and just see I just the fact that it
just takes too much time to read all the
terms okay now you think well I don't
know some of you might secretly be
thinking so what I've signed on clicked
on so many of these they didn't really
hurt me what's the big deal right well
the terms actually can be pretty bad so
for example on this website you can
actually it says here that that if you
cancel an order
okay or there's a failed delivery
attempt then not only do you have to pay
for the delivery charges the full cost
of shipping handling you also have to
pay a 20-percent restocking fee okay it
also says that you can't complain
complain about their lousy service on
any social media or on a consumer
complaint board and if you do it'll cost
you it's kind of hard to figure out but
it but by my calculation it's at least
two hundred fifty dollars okay so you
can't even put on that facebook page
that I hate this website because they
never delivered the the good because
then they'll come and if you think
that's not going to happen actually and
not on this website there was another
company that went after a couple and
because they had posted a complaint on
one of these consumer gripe sites and
they said if you don't take down this
negative review under our Terms of Use
says that we can charge you i think it
was thirty five hundred dollars okay and
so they said ah and they tried to take
it down but the problem was the grippe
site wouldn't take it down and they said
if you want us to take down you have to
go through arbitration process and
that'll cost you twenty-five hundred
dollars why they're there i mean there
are but most people are the funny thing
is these clauses when you read some of
these cases the early cases they had to
do with opportunistic users people who
are like web scraping content that's
where you get this bad law right but but
what you really don't see are
opportunistic consumers who are doing
things like this to get around you know
this provision is is it a little out of
hand right i mean no i think that if you
actually knew this provision was in the
contract you advice from another website
you wouldn't you don't need to go to
this website but the problem is you
don't because you don't know that it's
in here until what until you order
something it cut and it comes broken and
you try to return it and they say no and
you we're gonna try to a 20-percent
restocking fee too so alright so what's
the solution well i think that we have
this duty to read I think that there
should also be a duty to draft recently
which goes back to what Andy was talking
about earlier about I didn't see that or
on my browser how am I supposed to this
idea of construct notice that should be
the only thing we focus on we should
also look at well what else could the
company have done to make this contract
more readable to more noticeable okay
and that's not something the courts have
considered at all and this is why I
think code has a role to play here that
I think lawyers should not be the only
ones drafting these things we should
also look to to computer scientists and
to web designers and people to to sort
of implement a contract in a way that
makes sense for the user so look at it
from sort of a usability perspective
okay right now the law puts the burden
all on the user the consumer and it
doesn't put any sort of responsibility
on the drafter to make contracts more
reasonable they have all the drafting
power right the companies have all the
power to present the contracts and so
the relevance of code really comes into
play here because companies can make
these contracts more visible and they
can incorporate transactional hurdles to
make consumers sort of a wake up and
sort of pay attention to certain
provisions okay now there's a study
indicating the power of website design
and the role that computer scientists
can play in making contracts more
visible so there are some researchers
privacy they're doing research on
privacy they're researchers at carnegie
mellon that tried to test the impact of
reducing sort of privacy concerns and
what they did was they recruited some
university students to complete a survey
and there were two versions of the
survey the first was they called it the
frivolous version and it looked like
this they asked a lot of very personal
questions okay and you know the top said
how bad are you so it's all very sort of
hahaha right now the baseline version of
the survey look like this okay and it
was entitled cardigan
carnegie mellon university survey of
ethical standards it had a very
professional look the questions were the
same on both versions okay and they both
were just as nosy right they both asked
the same sensitive question right but
they found that participants in the
frivolous condition this one the devil
one we're on average one point seven
times more likely to admit to having
engaged in the behaviors that were
questioned than those in the baseline
condition ok so the context the way
something's presented really matters as
far as the way people engage with the
website and another unrelated Oh what
happened to be yeah we're likely to low
much more you give two different answers
that are you lying on the frivolous one
or are you lying on the formal one way
there's guessing that you're probably
telling the truth about Phyllis
condition because your work as scared
about the repercussions of getting found
out you let me guess you got an admiral
to ask you for telling the truth yeah no
I think that that happens kind of put
their at they're getting at but well
there are techniques the guys who had to
do aid surveys there are techniques
where you can get it better oh then just
say it saying that because they're
trying to protect and emitting that
particular case the guys on UCSF event
at the field is for decades oh and so
how so what they do is they do in an
organization procedure right where you
flip a coin I said whatever people in
Europe your answers well then they
didn't actually want to get the truth
they wanted that it wasn't because they
wanted answers to these questions and
they want to know formats hey whether or
not people valued of privacy differently
depending ever conduct now there's a
slide the figure I don't know where it
went that's why I keep flipping back and
forth but there was another study done
by two researchers math UK and Michael
Terry at the human-computer interaction
lab at the University of Waterloo and
they looked at visual design strategies
and I really wish I knew where that
slide would because it was very
interesting they use text bubble
and they used what they called textured
agreements to create visual interest and
they found that when they did people
spent more time an average of seven
seconds an average of 36 to 40 seconds
on on the agreement vs seven seconds on
each sort of page of the agreement and
they also found that longer reading
times correlated with greater retention
of information there was another study
done that presented privacy policies in
a nutrition label the new style
nutrition label format and they found
that people actually read the policies
and they actually thought it was more
enjoyable to read them and they were
able to retain the information more
accurately okay all right so I'm
obviously not a designer and right I'm
just I'm just a law professor even I so
this is my feeble attempt at making
these contracts a little more salient
okay so this is from facebook's page at
least at the time that I I copied the
page because they're constantly changing
it this is how they inform their
consider users of what they do with the
information obviously it's not presented
in a way that is going to get capture
anyone's attention who's not
specifically doing research on this
issue right okay so what happens if you
require an opt-in okay it's going to
annoy people right it will annoy people
because the more uses of their
information that you seek the more times
they have to click and the longer it's
going to take but that's kind of the
point right so that way you're forced to
deal with the amount of information
that's being taken from you okay but of
course they don't want to do that they
don't want to require opt-in because
they don't want you to know right okay
you can also raise awareness by
requiring confirmation so rather than
just having one click and you've agreed
to everything
why don't you make that your users you
send them an automated to email after
they sign up they do that anyway a lot
of times and have them actually typed
something back to you you can just have
them say yes i can send to letting
facebook use my information in any way
that it wants and then you add your name
you type in your name the date and the
email address and so that would sort of
overcome this habituation right okay
here's an indemnification clause that's
currently on the website and
indemnification Clause says that in the
event that something you do creates
trouble for them you are going to
protect them so you will pay their legal
fees most of you most people who signed
up have no idea that clauses in there
right I mean it's a it's a pretty
significant liability I'll tell you in
practice this is this is the one of the
most hotly contested negotiated
contractual provisions and here we all
are agreeing to them every time I go
online so how can we make this more
salient oops I don't know what's
happening to the slides here but um you
could put a you could put a well you
could put a danger icon and I had also
put in something that you type in and a
CAPTCHA just to overcome the consumer
habituation okay so this is what it
would look like okay so the idea is that
the courts have just made things too
easy for companies they've made it too
easy to force them to force us to enter
into agreements and so what what we
should what they should do is really
recognize the power that companies have
to manipulate and shape user behavior by
the way they present contracts the form
of the contracts and there's a real
danger to the contracting of everything
and this is that people fail to take
contact seriously and the challenge for
the law is to incorporate the work of
computer scientists and developers to
help design contracts in a way that that
is
in ways that are more effective and in
this way use code to bring some sense
back into contract law there any
questions yes it's too far field but
I've been saying for 20 at least since
1979 I've been saying something which
I'll tell you and after hearing you talk
I think I'm wrong and I'm going to tell
you what I think now and I hope you
correct that stage so I've been saying
corporations are just using contract law
to destroy common law and I always use
the example of the parking tonight no
that no baildon is created right which
is a common law concept which you are
destroying by putting it on a contract
now after hearing you speak I think I
have to say the courts are destroying
the common law by are destroying the old
common law by coming up with a new
column and this is all the design on the
law I think that's that's more your
first of all done so common law is the
law that courts make okay Beth we had
course they were just good trying to
know it was right well by the way that
we typically refer to come law is the
law that the case law right that the
courts make as opposed to statute
secretory and yeah I think that what's
happening here is that we have this we
had this body of contract law and then
we had sort of these business these
changes in the marketplace and companies
responding to these changes in the
marketplace by coming up with new ways
of presenting contract terms to sort of
chain because contracts come into play
when are a lot of different arenas but
the reason we're seeing so much of the
this now is that the technology is
moving a little more is a lot more
quickly than the law okay and so if you
have a company and you're not sure
whether or not what you're doing is
legal you're not going to sit there and
wait for the courts or the legislators
come down and say you can do this
so but at the same time you don't want
to get into too much trouble by doing
something you're not supposed to do so
what do you do well you can you can
resort to private law meaning if I'm a
company and I'm not sure whether or not
I can track your move it online and then
sell them to somebody at a third party
I'm not sure that's okay and believe it
or not i think twenty years ago people
weren't sure that was ok because it
probably wasn't it seems kind of an
ethical you might think and so you think
well it i'm not sure if i can do that
but I know I can do it if what if you
say I can and so how am I going to make
sure that you say I cannot have a sign a
contract but if you sign a contract
you're never going to use my website I
know I'll have to have you sign a
contract without knowing you're signing
a contract that seemed to work pretty
well and that's where we have the
Internet of today didn't have to look
like this right it did it didn't have to
look the way it does now with all the
data problems and security issues but um
it's kind of where we are and we kind of
have to deal with that two things one
website designers are not in a position
to make these decisions to say oh we're
going to present it in a nice way but
ignoring that particular problem how can
notice work both ways and by that I mean
facebook says to keep picking on
facebook and i don't think they're
especially bad that you agree to their
terms because you've done these things
you've done constructive notice arm but
but facebook didn't have to I didn't
facebook and I didn't have to negotiate
that contract that's just the contract
that they presented and I accept it
right if I'd presented a contract and
they'd accepted we'd have a different
contract rate so how can I use notice to
have them agree to a different contract
that perhaps they didn't see because
they didn't read my terms but there's
still bound because they had
constructive notice yeah you some people
have tried that and and I think the
courts aren't going to buy that
and the reason is there aren't a lot of
kiss I've actually been because I've
been reading news stories about
consumers doing this for example they'll
send an email to a company and it gets
lost a week you know we chat we change
the terms or they'll do like you did not
not not read but they'll say something
like they'll put some proviso in there
they usually turn do it by writing on
the check this is payment in full on the
first mortgage yeah but that's a
different yet so that's a different sort
of situation but when we're talking
these automated or when you're talking
about sort of the digital contract what
for a while I don't know if any of you
something there was something going
around Facebook that said something
there was a very encouraging people to
say I own all my data or something like
that that was it was one of these things
that kind of became kind of popular but
under contract law the you okay so when
you sign it with Facebook they have a
provision that says that they can make
changes to their website to their terms
of use if you make changes and you send
it to them they have to agree somehow it
is a constructive notice no but okay oh
I had constructive notice they have
constructive notice but see if you use
but if you think about it the way that I
I think the courts and I think all of us
should think about it as a sort of
property issue what is the thing that
you are attaching to the notice what
other than your personal data right
which supposedly you agreed to give up
which is a thing of value we would say I
wish it's a thing of God and so so
according to facebook the exchange there
the the bargain as we say in contract
law is they let use their services
without charging your money and you let
them use your data so when you put the
nut so what where would you attach that
notice it's the problem
the ietf couldn't adopt a standard what
about when you post to a website there's
this protocol when you can put things in
that protocol that's the thing there are
my theory is that if judges only knew
what companies could do to make their
contracts more noticeable more effective
more fair then they might approach they
might analyze these cases a little more
different a little differently but
because they're just looking at it in
the way the way it's presented to them
they're applying sort of the the world
the physical world sort of textual ideas
and in this in this realm that is very
visual and where you know the
presentation of the contract is
everything and instead what they're
doing it is they're saying no this is
just like that parking ticket but it's
the fact is it's not like the parking
ticket why because the parking ticket
yes two sides you can only fit so much
on two sides of a you know 2-inch square
of paper right but you 50 pages right if
you hip if you hit all the hyperlinks so
it's not that it's not the same thing
and I think that that's something that
tends to get overlooked and so yeah
you're right it's not that you know it's
not like the the the IT folks can
actually think okay you got to do
something you know to be the marketing
people but um that's kind of what I'm
trying to do and if in any of you I
could but I'm you know I think that if
there have to be more studies out there
about because right now the big thing in
in the law is people don't read their
contracts it doesn't matter what you put
in them because people don't read them
anyhow I think that's too easy I think
that's giving up too easily it's people
don't read them because they're not
presented in a way that's written that
they're readable and even if people
can't chain
to the terms even if they can't
negotiate it doesn't mean they wouldn't
read the terms for example that that one
website i showed you you can't negotiate
with that company but you don't have to
buy from them
you